begin with chaotic weather in California
and a rush to clean up from record
rainfall a New Year's storm brought
deadly flooding high winds and
landslides to the northern part of the
state along with many feet of snow
shutting down roads and stranding
drivers Jonathan Vigliotti is an Elk
Grove California one of the worst
affected areas Jonathan good morning
Happy New Year
and happy New Year to you Vlad this
morning we're in a neighborhood just
outside of Sacramento that this morning
looks more like a lake after a levy in
the area was breached over the holiday
weekend the residents in this flooded
out home among hundreds in the area that
are under a mandatory evacuation the
river that caused all this flooding has
crested this morning but there is more
rain in the forecast for Wednesday
it's been a race to Higher Ground in
Northern California after a massive
storm brought severe downpours this
holiday weekend many residents in
Sacramento County have been ordered to
evacuate after the historic rains
breached at least two levees authorities
calling the situation incredibly
dangerous and I told myself but no I'm
not saying I don't feel safe there are
growing concerns that swollen Rivers
could continue to rise this morning
after they overflowed onto nearby
roadways First Responders rescued at
least a dozen stranded drivers from the
air and through the flood waters that
turned deadly for at least one person
near the town of Wilton a person was
found deceased who had been trying to
drive through the water across Northern
California neighborhoods have been
submerged while landslides blocked
roadways powerful wind gusts up to 60
miles per hour downed trees causing
power outages for tens of thousands
in the Bay Area San Francisco's iconic
Fisherman's Wharf experienced its
wettest day in nearly 30 years and the
Oakland Zoo will remain closed for at
least the next two weeks after a huge
sinkhole there collapsed at its entrance
this is crazy I've never seen it so deep
here the atmospheric River brought more
than eight feet of snow to the Sierra
Nevadas which shut down roads and even
closed many ski resorts as the system
heads East through the Rockies Avalanche
warnings are in effect after a skier was
killed near Breckenridge Colorado and
another Avalanche was caught on camera
from downtown Telluride this weekend
and back here in California the rain
that has landed here in the valley
impacting areas previously destroyed and
damaged by wildfires what are known as
bird scars this soil terrible at
absorbing water and this morning a bit
of a paradox because all this rain is
actually welcome for a state in the
midst of a years-long historic drought
meteorologists though say at this point
is still unclear if this rainfall will
have any kind of impact in the state's
threatened water supply Ed
Jonathan thank you that